Speaker 1: Let's go next to Ford from Louisiana.
Ford, what's going on? Do you have power?
Speaker 3: Yes, I do can hear it. Yes, I can. All
right, wonderful. Yeah, I just we evacuated to
Alabama with some family and I
just got back today to my apartment
in Baton Rouge right next to LSU. So we have
power, OK? A lot of my buddies don't. I know one
of my buddies stayed over by roommate. So a lot of
people still don't have power here. Yeah, I'm from
the North Shore right north of New Orleans, and
that place got devastated. So like the lakefront
was flooding and most people still have power. So
it's pretty crazy scenes over there. Well, glad
Speaker 1: to hear you've got
power. I know many people still
don't. And hopefully they'll get it back soon.
Speaker 3: Yeah, so my question has to do with,
I guess, cultural divides in the US. I
think that the largest cultural divide
in the U.S. has to be between urban and
rural populations. Do you agree with that?
Speaker 1: Um. Yeah. I mean, that's a
I hesitate to say that's the biggest.
There is a huge cultural divide between
urban and rural. The question is whether
it's because of that or whether it's that more
conservative people are choosing to live, really,
whereas more liberal people are choosing, you
know, it's kind of a chicken egg thing. But I
think you can find a divide there for sure.
Speaker 3: OK, I think I agree with that,
so I feel as though people in rural areas of the
country and a lot of right wingers probably in
general, than to base their politics on personal
experience. And I think it's fine to integrate
some level of your personal life experience
in your politics, but I think their politics
tends to be completely based on that. Yeah.
So the issue that arises from that is that I
think people in rural communities tend to be
extremely similar to one another in general.
So the life experiences of these people have are
informed by people who are extremely similar to
them. So it kind of feels like a feedback loop
because there's like a good solution to this.
Speaker 1: The solution, I don't know.
But I think you're spot on, which is
we we might hope that people use empiricism rather
than anecdote in order to inform themselves.
Given that a lot of people are going
to use anecdote in personal experience,
it would be better if people's personal experience
was more varied. But when everybody you're around
is the same as you, it's likely that your
personal experience is merely going to be
signal boost that. I think. I think that there's
certainly a lot there's a lot to that. I mean,
the solution would be. Finding a way I don't I
don't think the solution is to dump rural people
into cities and think that that's going to
magically solve the problem. I think it's
actually in getting people to think empirically
rather than anecdotally from a young age. So it
goes back to teaching critical thinking.
If from from sixth grade on, you are told
anecdotes don't tell the story. And here's how
you actually figure out what's going on. I think
that that's the best possible thing we could do.
Speaker 3: OK, that's a good point. Do you think
they're giving these people like broadband
infrastructure and better Internet would
kind of help them expose themselves to to
more ideas, maybe through the Internet?
Speaker 1: Or I would love to say yes, except
we know that for a lot of these right wingers,
the Internet is where they're getting radicalized.
So it's hard like I mean, at the big picture,
I want high speed Internet for everybody. That's
that's an infrastructure thing. That's an access
thing. At the same time, I know that the echo
chambers online reinforce a lot of the beliefs
people have rather than disabusing them. So it's
not clear to me that it's some kind of panacea.
Speaker 3: Yeah, that's a really good point,
I actually don't even consider that, you know,
all this misinformation for a country
like these Facebook groups is depressing.
Speaker 1: Depressing.
Speaker 3: Yeah, it is. And,
you know, I know a lot of these people and I'm
from the Deep South, so I feel there are a lot of
these people. I know they're not necessarily bad
people, but just when that's what you grow up with
and that's all you know, that's all you really
know. This is hard to do anything about it for.
Speaker 1: I'm curious, how do you lack any
kind of very stigmatizing Southern accent?
Speaker 3: I mean, I'm from the Deep South, my dad
doesn't really have an accent, my mom has a has a
very large accent. But I think I think I've always
been on the Internet a lot ever since I was pretty
young. Yeah. A lot of voice that I heard just
ended up being typical American voices. So even
though I know a lot of people with harsh country
accents, most of my buddies don't have like these
sorts of accents. It's not as common as maybe it
was. I'm also not from like a super rural area,
so I could explain it to. All right.
Speaker 1: Well, that's it seems like a
reasonable explanation. I appreciate it.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Thank you so much for
taking my call, David. All right.
Speaker 1: Stay safe there. Ford
from Louisiana. We are having really good luck
today with calls. I really don't want to jinx it
because that would just be bad. By the way,
I just is just a note to people on discord
trying to call me directly when we're taking
live calls or sending me direct messages. It'll
just get you blocked. It's not going to get you
on the show. We have a queue and we go through
the queue and that that's the only way to get
on. So please, let's let's ease up on that.
Let's go to Paul Garcia from
Mexico. Paul from Mexico.
You're on the air.
Speaker 3: If you want
to make a graph here, the. Now, in the movies,
when Sam was just the S&P, the employee is funded
by the ABC Oil. Implicit in is when I was
Speaker 1: there watching problems, yeah,
it said when when time is zero, X is twenty four,
they seem to be watching math videos while waiting
on hold for me. That's too bad because I would
have loved to have spoken to someone from Mexico.
Let's go to Christian from California next.
Christian, you're on the air, I guess. Are you
surrounded by BS? What is that noise.
Speaker 3: I'm sorry. I'm walking
through a park and there is at least
blower. I'm going to try something.
Speaker 1: This is how our leaf
blowers, even legal, quite frankly,
it is one of the most oppressive noises.
Speaker 3: You know, your guess is as
good as mine. My question for you today was and
this current day and political landscape, I mean,
do you think it's even possible for even
party to get a filibuster proof majority?
Speaker 1: I think it would be very tough.
I think it would be very tough. I think that
you would need to see I mean, like think
as crazy as the Trump administration was,
Democrats barely even took the Senate. I think
it would be really, really tough. And part of
that is because of how, you know, when we
say a state is really red or really blue,
often what we mean is that it's like 60
to 40 percent, one or the other. You know,
it's like it's the margin is still not that
big, even sometimes 58, 42. I think a filibuster
proof majority would be really tough right now.
Speaker 3: So given that, I mean, are we sort of
doomed for incrementalism for the foreseeable
future? It's kind of hard to say, oh, God.
Speaker 1: The dog and now with the audio's cut.
Speaker 3: There is time for, I guess,
democracy as a
Speaker 1: Christian,
I lost about 15 seconds there and now there's
a dog barking, so I'm going to let you go, OK?
OK. All right. It's too crazy, it's just it's
way too crazy there. Let's do this just because
people are getting all fired up from the
leaf blower. Let's take a quick break.
But I'm going to go right back to
calls in a moment. So don't hang
up if you're holding on to talk to me.
And I will be right with you. Stand by